[Música]
i
bienvenidos a frank se enfocó su cita
con la actualidad francesa por las
pantallas de atrás 24 como estamos en
las cercanías de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones presidenciales este
capítulo lo dedicaremos enteramente a la
política francesa
[Aplausos]
y
[Música]
las encuestas en estos comicios podría
haber una alta abstención que supera
incluso el récord de hace diez años
cuando un 28 por ciento del electorado
no fue a votar en primera vuelta esto
preocupa sobre todo a emanuel macrón
cuyo casi seguro pasó a la segunda
vuelta podría desmotivar un electorado
menos fiel que el de la extrema derecha
el reportaje es de malla de dieta girl y
nata chávez mix va a ir a votar y vote
folleto tras folleto esta militante
comunista no renuncia quiere llevar de
regreso a las urnas a tantos
abstencionistas como sea posible los
buscaremos uno por uno es una verdadera
lacra
desgraciadamente la democracia sufrí en
novia billie una de las comunas más
pobres de francia hoy el iii debe
convencer a unos votantes completamente
desilusionados hacen lindas promesas
lindas palabras y luego no cumplen no
confío en nadie nadie puede representar
mis intereses
la abstención en france ha alcanzado
niveles alarmantes los votantes ya no se
identifican con la oferta política
estamos en un país donde la desconfianza
hacia las instituciones es
particularmente alta en comparación con
sus vecinas pero no son sólo factores
políticos hay también factores
sociodemográficos los jóvenes votan
mucho menos que los mayores las
categorías populares también votan mucho
menos
lesivo como para volver a interesar en
la política y hacerla más atractiva
aplicaciones como hélice se están
inspirando en otras de citas estos
alumnos analizan 25 propuestas de
candidatos instaurar el derecho de voto
a los 16 años yo diría que no no no
estamos de acuerdo demasiado joven
demasiado temprano desliza en el dedo
hacia la derecha si están de acuerdo o a
la izquierda si no lo están la
aplicación les indica entonces con cuál
candidato tienen más afinidad existe el
objetivo es ayudar a cualquier joven que
se interese en la elección a comprender
mejor los programas y elegir mejor pero
somos neutrales independientes
pero si se trata de encontrar con que
candidatos encaja mejor por qué no
hacerlo a través de tender el sitio de
citas no permite el uso de su servicio
con fines políticos pero sea una
asociación anti abstencionismo con la
consigna si sale cerca de tu casa
entonces vota cerca de tu casa partió
siendo uno de los temas más importantes
para los franceses pero la ecología ha
ido perdiendo terreno primero frente a
la seguridad tema favorito de la derecha
y luego el poder adquisitivo fuertemente
impactado por la guerra en ucrania pese
a ello según una última encuesta el
medio ambiente sigue siendo importante
para un 94% de los electores el
reportaje es de malla anaís de tiger
quedan algunos días para las elecciones
presidenciales pero queda menos tiempo
para enfrentar el cambio climático
estos manifestantes pidieron a los
candidatos que miren hacia arriba como
leonardo dicaprio en la película don't
look up una metáfora de la inacción ante
el calentamiento global el tema ya poco
presente la campaña quedó completamente
eclipsado por la guerra de ucrania
no se habla para nada no veo ni las
noticias estoy harta el debate político
no está centrado en lo esencial o en lo
que se puede anticipar esto es cada vez
más urgente y me da la sensación de que
en los hechos científicamente probados
hacen actuar a la gente entre la
multitud varios candidatos de izquierda
incluido el icm en acción que aboga por
la planificación ecológica
miren el programa del que les parezca
estar a la altura de circunstancias
yo soy simpático y no les digo que sólo
el mío tiene las respuestas aunque sea
la verdad verdad el ecologista y
aniquilado también dan desafío la
llovizna parisina pero pone un clima
cueste lo que cueste confirma su
voluntad de eliminar progresivamente la
energía nuclear y acabar con la
dependencia a los combustibles fósiles
touré cumple con todos los favores
políticos que demandan las energías
fósiles están matando la democracia lo
vemos en ucrania pero también matan el
clima y vamos la socialista anne hidalgo
abordó el balance del gobierno macrón
llevamos cinco años gobernados por un
presidente que le dio la espalda al tema
climático que consideró que no era un
tema que además fue condenado en su
propio país por una de las más altas
jurisdicción el consejo de estado por su
inacción climática según un estudio
reciente el clima es un tema considerado
capital por el 94 por ciento de los
franceses especialmente los más jóvenes
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y como hemos venido haciéndolo en los
capítulos anteriores hoy les presentamos
los dos últimos perfiles de los
candidatos al emir
[Música]
esperó hasta último minuto para declarar
su candidatura y apenas hacerlo la
guerra en ucrania lo propulsó en los
sondeos emanuel matrona aprovechó esta
coyuntura para no debatir con sus
contrincantes y presentar un programa
que muchos califican cargado a la
derecha el perfil es de floja jodo
algunos los sueñan toda la vida el
doctor o el santo grial a sus 39 años en
manuel marco es de lejos el presidente
más joven de la quinta república
historia de un hombre con prisa amante
del piano y de la filosofía graduado de
la escuela nacional de administración y
economista después de su notable paso
por el banco rothschild el nativo de
amia descubrió el elíseo nombrado
secretario general adjunto a sus 34 años
ya era parte del círculo más cercano del
presidente
y mucho más aparte de este tríptico es
todo lo que se hace detrás
dos años después el ambicioso
treintañeros ya era ministro de economía
su ascenso fulgurante despertó la
curiosidad por dondequiera que pasara lo
esperaban los micrófonos en manuel mac
con anunció sus ambiciones de manera muy
concreta quitar las trabas que hay en
nuestra economía e m son sus iniciales y
también las de su movimiento en marcha
que creó en 2016 se distanció del
socialista françois hollande
yo soy de izquierda esa ha sido mi
historia pero hoy en día la izquierda no
me satisface el tótem de la izquierda es
la semana laboral de 35 horas una trampa
se une manuel ma con el prefiere ver a
los franceses trabajando no me asustan
con su camiseta la mejor manera de
pagarse un traje es trabajar a depto de
al mismo tiempo mac con revoluciona el
paisaje político nacional la
presidencial de 2017 pasó a la historia
por primera vez en la quinta república
ni la izquierda ni la derecha tuvieron
segunda vuelta el europeísta emanuel
manjón venció a ma jin open
menos de 40 años inició un quinquenio
lejos de ser tranquilo chalecos
amarillos acaso ven a la manifestación
contra la reforma de las pensiones
pandemia de kobe 19 las dificultades se
multiplicaron las críticas también el
presidente discutía con los franceses
nos hemos convertido en una nación de 66
millones de fiscales
los últimos dos años de su mandato se
desarrollaron bajo la crisis sanitaria
para solucionarlo el jefe de estado
quiso vacunar a diestra y siniestra aún
a riesgo de fastidiar a los reacios no
sólo ponen en peligro la vida de los
demás sino que también limitan la
libertad de los demás y eso no lo puedo
aceptar ahora candidato a su propia
sucesión
emanuel mccone quiere triunfar allí
donde sus dos predecesores con su balón
y nicolas sarkozy fracasaron quedarse
cinco años más en el elíseo
dio la sorpresa al ganar la primaria de
la derecha frente al favoritos y fans
valérie pécresse es la candidata del
partido de los republicanos y una de las
cuatro mujeres en competencias sin
embargo con el correr de los días su
desempeño a los mítines ha decepcionado
así como algunas de sus ideas rozando la
extrema derecha el perfil es de floja
modo es bien sabido en las campañas
presidenciales los golpes vienen de
todas partes por suerte valérie pécresse
es una entusiasta del boxeo y sabe
recibirlos la joven que proviene de un
medio favorecido también tiene prisa con
su diploma de secundaria en la mano a
los 16 años ingresó a la escuela de
estudios superiores de comercio y luego
a la escuela nacional de administración
tomó un desvío por el consejo de estado
y regresó en 1998 atrajo la mirada de
jacques chirac y dio sus primeros pasos
en el elíseo la especialista en nuevas
tecnologías introdujo el presidente al
internet nada más y nada menos
después pécresse se entregó en cuerpo y
alma a la reelección de su campeón la
pelea acaba con una victoria ko en la
segunda ronda frente a jean marie le pen
ayudar al triunfo de los demás también
es pensar en el propio en junio de 2022
la heredera de chirac dio el salto y se
convirtió en diputada del departamento
de evelyn con él fue muy emocionante
porque cuando uno es consejero y luego
se vuelve actor cuando uno pasa de la
sombra a la luz y llega a la asamblea
nacional se siente el miedo al tomar la
palabra por primera vez en el hemiciclo
portavoz del gobierno de nicolas sarkozy
dos veces ministra tres veces diputada
valérie pécresse se entró a boxear en el
ring de las grandes ligas
realmente necesitamos modelos femeninos
que triunfen en política tenemos a la
señora ágil a la señora base lo que está
imputado y pronto tendremos a la señora
pérez
que me gustaría que mi triunfo pueda ser
un símbolo y tenga mucha repercusión
trabajadora en 2015 obtuvo una nueva
medalla la región isla de francia te
creés la liberal conservadora impuso sus
ideas en el ring político se distanció
de su partido los republicanos antes de
regresar al redil en diciembre pasado
derrotó a los pesos pesados michel
barnier javier hand y luego a eric
ciotti vencedora de la primaria se
erigió como la candidata que llevaría a
la derecha a la presidencial gran
primicia para una mujer la campaña ha
sido la oportunidad para volver a sacar
el cupcake de nicolas sarkozy jacques
caída quiero ir tras los cabecillas los
delincuentes los traficantes tus
predicadores del odio si volveré a sacar
a carchi ya tiene puestos los guantes
vale quiere hacer historia
[Aplausos]
y hasta aquí este capítulo de francia-
enfocó muchas gracias por habernos
acompañado y hasta una próxima